we're on problem 87 machine a produces
parts twice as fast as machine B does so
machine a produces a hundred parts twice
as fast as machine B let me just keep
reading machine B produces 100 parts and
40 minutes so B produces 100 parts in 40
minutes so that's equal to what 100
divided by 40 that's two point five
parts per minute and they told us a
produces it twice as fast so a is going
to be twice that so a is going to be
five parts per minute five parts per
minute okay if each machine produces
parts at a constant rate how much how
many parts does machine a produce in six
minutes
so five parts per minute so times six
minutes six minutes is equal to what
minutes cancel out six times five is
thirty parts choice a 88 the necklace is
made by stringing n individual beads
together in the repeating pattern red
bead green bead white bead C so red
green white blue and then yellow and you
keep repeating if the necklace begins
with a red bead and ends with a white
bead then n could be equal to so let's
think about it it starts with a red bead
right it starts with the red bead and
ends with a white bead so let's think
about this if it if it's exactly a
multiple of five right if if we if n is
equal to if n is equal to exactly the
number of beads in this pattern then
it'll always end with a yellow right so
if n is equal to some multiple of five
right you know could be five it could be
ten or whatever then you're going to end
with a yellow bead right that makes
sense if you have ten you'd you just
have the pattern twice if
it is equal to five some multiple of
five plus one then you're always going
to complete the cycle completely and
then you're going to have one more
you're going to end with the red bead
right I think you see the pattern here
if n is equal to some multiple of five
and then it has two left over or it's
windows divided by five it has a
remainder of two you're going to end
with the green bead right you're going
to the multiple five part you're going
to complete all the way to yellow then
you're gonna have one two left and so if
n is equal to a multiple of five plus
three then you're going to end with a
white bead so multiple of five plus
three is essentially any any number that
ends with either an eight or three right
because a multiple of five ends with
either a five or a zero so let's see
what choices they give us they give us
sixteen doesn't not a multiple five plus
three
thirty-two not a multiple of five plus
three 41 is not fifty four is not 68
that is a multiple of five plus three
sixty-five plus 3 right 65 is thirteen
times five that's equal to 13 times five
plus three so the choice is e problem 89
89 in the XY coordinate system if a
comma B a comma B and a plus 3 B plus K
are two points on the line defined by
the equation X is equal to 3 y minus 7
then K is equal to what okay well I
think an easier thing to do an easier
thing to do is to well actually we could
we could just stay well let's just
define Y in terms of X so you get X plus
7 is equal to 3 y Y is equal to 1/3 X
plus 7 over 3 okay let's see what we
could do so what's so the slope of this
line is 1/3
right those if you remember from Alice
MX plus B form but this is this is how
fast the line goes up or down this 1/3
right every move to the right in X by 1
you're moving up in Y by 1/3 so what's
the slope if you give if you're giving
if you give me two points what's the
slope what's the change in Y over the
change in X and all so I'll call this y1
and this is y2 so or point one and point
two so you could say change in Y is B
plus K the ladder Y point minus the
first Y point over a plus three minus a
right and what is this reduced to so B
plus K minus B B's cancel out a plus
three minus a is canceled out I'm left
with K over 3 and that equals the slope
we already know that the slope is equal
to 1/3 K over three is equal to 1/3 so K
is equal to 1 K is equal to 1 is choice
D problem 90 problem 90 at the rate of M
meters per second so M meters per second
how many meters does a cyclist travel in
X minutes so X minutes so remember this
is tricky there said X meters per second
right how many meters are the cycles
travel in X minutes so let's get X in
terms of seconds so X minutes is just
going to be 60 X seconds right because
you have 60 seconds per minute so 60 X
seconds and distance is equal to rate
times time hopefully that's a little bit
of intuition to you for you or now but
the rate is equal to M meters per second
and he's traveling for 60 X seconds so
you get M times 60 X which is 60 M X and
seconds times meters per second that's
meters so 60 MX meters 60 M X 60 let's
see
how many meters is a cyclist travel in X
minutes X minutes right X minutes is 60
X seconds at the rate how many meters is
a cycle travel right rate times time at
a rate of M meters per second I think I
think they've they've made a I think
they've made a boo-boo here because they
have to have the 60 60 M 60 M oh I see
mistake I made they say okay let me let
me redo it my bad they said at the rate
of M meters per s seconds so the
cyclists rate is actually M / S meters
per second that's confusing because well
they said that s seconds and I thought
they said oh and meters per second oh
but it's a rate of M meters per s
seconds how many meters of trout does
the cyclist travel in X minute which we
know is 60 which we know is 60 if it's X
minutes is 60 X seconds so you multiply
the rate times the time and you get 60 m
x right M X / s which is choice E and it
saved me that my original answer wasn't
anywhere in any of the choices problem
91 if Sam were twice as old as he is he
would be 40 years older than Jim so two
times Sam so Sam were twice as old as he
is so Sam s is Sam's current age if Sam
were twice as old age as he is he would
be 40 years older than Jim so he would
be Jim plus 40 if Jim is 10 years
younger than Sam how old is Sam so Sam
Jim is 10 years younger than Sam so we
could say Sam is Jim plus 10 could have
also said Sam minus 10 is equal to Jim
same thing
let's see what we could do here let's
see if how how best we can solve this
equation they want to know how old is
Sam so let's we want to solve for s so
let's do something let's subtract this
equation from that equation so 2's minus
s is s J minus J is 0 40 minus 10 is 30
so Sam is 30 and we're done and there's
a lot of ways you could have done that
you could have substituted you could
have solved for J and substitute in here
and then solved would have taken a
little bit more time but we just
subtracted this equation from that and
you got s is equal to 30 which is choice
B choice B and I think I'm about out of
time so I'll continue into the next
video see you soon